build build build is the mantra
that's right the prime minister's
setting out
uh some of the plans that we've got to
to bounce forward as he's uh
as he's putting it to make sure that
in response to the terrible economic
consequences of this virus
that we can really get the country back
on our feet as much as possible
and that includes investment going in
right now into hospitals
into schools and getting going with some
of those
long-standing road building projects
that have been really necessary
uh in some parts of the country and
really it's about an approach
which is the approach that we were
elected on just six months ago
of leveling up the country because we
want the economic
recovery that after this uh crisis to be
one where
the economy is stronger and we
deal with some of the long-standing
british problems like under investment
and so he he's getting going on that
right now and i'm very glad that a
significant
portion of the extra funding will be
going into accelerating our hospital
building project
is it possible though that we can set
aside the somewhat spurious comparisons
to
to fdr in his new deal we're talking
about five billion pounds of spending
much of which is already being announced
i mean the new deal cost 650 billion
dollars
you know despite what the prime minister
is going to be saying later on it
doesn't sound particularly rooseveltian
to me it doesn't sound like a new deal
well i totally disagree it's about a a
direction and attitude and of course the
immediate funding we can get it underway
with
you know there is a there is a big
economic
uh cost to this uh to this crisis that's
obvious
and the argument that the prime minister
has been making and we'll be making in
dudley is that you've got to you've got
to build your way out of that
and you've got to deal with some of the
long-standing underlying problems like
uh
like of under investment that have long
dogged the
the british economy and the way that we
live and so
making sure that we for instance deliver
on the health infrastructure that i'm
responsible for
building that we deliver on the
transport infrastructure
and this is the agenda on which we were
elected
and it's uh it's five billion pounds but
it's also a very clear direction travel
that we're going to put that
investment in and especially to the
parts of the country that just haven't
had the
uh the the investment in the growth in
the
over the past generations actually this
isn't about indeed
recent times it's about generation let's
turn our attention then
then to lester um yesterday in your
statement to the commons it was all
about
recommending we're recommending uh
nothing but essential travel
recommending staying at home at what
point will the government
compel people how will this be enforced
well we will be bringing forward a legal
change
very shortly in the next couple of days
because
the some of the measures that we've
unfortunately had to take in leicester
will be will require a legal
underpinning
so then it's going to be enforced by the
police is it uh yes
in some cases uh so on the on the
question of um
shops being open we'll be making the
legal change so that
uh non-essential retail is no longer
open
and and clearly uh directly we can
we will communicate with the schools
because
schools unfortunately are going to have
to close from thursday
and we are recommending that people
stay at home when they can but again
just on that point
we we have precious little time this
morning we're afraid to administer
how will that be enforced the 6th of
june plenty of places not that far away
from leicester
pubs will be reopening what is to stop
people from leicester
you know driving down the roads at
coventry sutton coalfield loughborough
darby nottingham
actually if you put your foot down
barnard castle's just two and a half
hours up the road
well we're recommending against all but
essential travel
both to and from and within leicester
and as we saw during the during the peak
the vast majority of people
will abide by uh these rules now
i of course will take further action
including
uh putting in place uh laws if that's
necessary but i
very much hope that it won't be you know
this is a local lockdown to deal with a
very specific problem
in leicester i set out yesterday that
unfortunately the number of cases in
leicester
is around three times higher her head of
population than
the next highest place so i i think you
know my heart goes out for people of
leicester
everybody was really looking forward to
the to the opening up that was
that's due to play take place and will
take place with the rest of the country
on saturday but unfortunately the
problem is mr hancock the problem is
this that
actually there doesn't appear to be an
awful lot of common sense on display and
you're asking people to rely on their
common sense
the beaches of brighton and bournemouth
how many illegal raves have we seen
brixton clapham common tooting back
common stratum
common notting hill maid of ale
manchester oldham
look at what the liverpool fans did i
mean you're asking people to use their
common sense when there is plenty of
evidence that suggests
people aren't well you know it's it's
easy to look at the
exceptions the vast majority of people
are doing the right thing
and i'm grateful and i applaud them and
it's in everybody's interest that we do
so
and and of course we're prepared to take
action where that is necessary that's
you know what we've said all along in
terms of local action and and last night
we had to take that decision in
leicester
this is the this is the the whack-a-mole
strategy uh
the the prime minister of straight face
described this as yesterday and
it has been a couple of years since i
saw boris johnson down there arcades and
in blackpool but whack-a-mole isn't a
strategy it's entirely
reactive you're quashing an infection
after we see the r number rise
i mean it's it it's almost a better
analogy isn't it from the way that the
government has been behaving
over the past few weeks coveted 19 and
care homes pops up we'll deal with that
ppe not getting to the front line we'll
deal with that it's not a strategy
when are we going to start getting
proactive on this uh
no i i think the way that you put it is
actually exactly the opposite of the
case
because the strategy is to be to allow
for
the opening up of the rest of the and
the rest of the country to giving
people their freedoms back where it's
safe to do so
we also need alongside that to take
local action where there's a specific
flare-up
so we watch the data
the analogy doesn't even work on that
basis because in guacamole a mole pops
up
and you hit it it's been 11 days since
we knew that there was a situation in
leicester
well i i'll just finish my answer and
the the whole point
is that you watch the data and then when
you see
a uh when you see a problem arising
then you immediately take action that's
what we've done
in leicester we've done it also in
keithley for instance
uh the the welsh government have done it
in
uh north wales in wrexham in anglesey
we've done it in western superman
now if further actions then needed for
instance
what we did in leicester last night
and then of course we're willing to take
it but yes we're taking
um action rapidly in outbreaks where we
see them right across the country
in some cases it's for instance closing
to gp surgeries
in enfield so as a very small targeted
action
but if the outbreak continues um as it
has done
in leicester even despite the fact that
we've been engaged in
um almost two dozen different workplaces
where there's a problem
we the schools some of the schools were
closed um
last week we've been taking action we've
put in those extra mobile testing units
there comes a point when you have to
take broader action that's what we've
done
can we talk briefly about about the
schools and indeed the the situation
with the children
in leicester a number of parents myself
included there are years
up yesterday when you mentioned the the
the impact that this was
was having on children not on their
health but indeed on
on their role in transmission of kovid
19.
i'm just wondering if whether or not we
we have an r number
for school age people in leicester and
why we're not closing the schools today
you can't get an r number that is uh
that
localized what you have to do is look
for individual
uh cases and in the in the very
significant testing
um that we've brought into leicester
with those mobile testing units
we have seen a number of positive cases
in the under 18s
and that's why we took the decision and
with a heavy heart has to be said
to um to close schools in leicester
and in in leicestershire within the
leicester connotation and and um and and
and so you know it there is a and the
good news is it's really important to
stress this for people watching
um not only in leicester but across the
country is that the risk to children
themselves is very
very low it's one of the saving graces
of this virus
but of course children can still
transmit um just just one question mr
hancock i know it's slightly off your
brief
what about financial assistance targeted
to to to lester
and perhaps other parts of the country
that might be entering local lockdown
what happens if you can't work if if the
schools are closed some of the financial
assistance that the government has
has provided is beginning to come to an
end this week and we're looking at two
weeks at least
of lockdown in leicester well look it's
a really important question
the furlough scheme remains and is there
but we've also put in
um money to the local councils so that
on a discretionary basis they can use
that to support people who
who need further support um that's both
for
communications but also if there's
specific instances
you know it's far better that's done by
the council on the ground
responding very locally to different
concerns
so it's a it's a really important
consideration you say it's off my
briefes
not really because you know you've got
to look after
you've got to support people as best we
can through what is a a very difficult
decision